hallo liebe leute für ein paar monaten
haben wir bereits ein video über ein
typisches wg leben gedreht
falls ihr das verpasst habt könnt ihr
euch das gerne ich hier nochmal
anschauen
wir wissen dass in deutschland ist
schwierig sein kann vor allen dingen in
den großstädten ein wg zimmer zu finden
deswegen haben wir gedacht drehen wir
heute ein video mit den wichtigsten
schritten um einen leichteren start bei
der suche zu haben
fragen die du dir am anfang der suche
stellen sollte ist wie viel geld kannst
du für ein wg zimmer oder eine wohnung
ausgeben schreibe ein profil über dich
wer bist du was machst du was du deine
hobbys diesen kannst du dann immer etwas
abgewandelt an verschiedene wgs senden
in welchem viertel der stadt möchtest du
leben das ist praktisch für dich bedenkt
dass manche vierte einer stadt teurer
sein können als andere viertel in berlin
zum beispiel gibt es einen ring
dies bezeichnet eine s-bahn-linie die um
das zentrum von berlin rom fährt wenn
ihr innerhalb des rings ist es
wahrscheinlich teurer als außerhalb des
rings welche dokumente brauchst du die
dokumente variieren von ort zu ort aber
das hier sind jetzt erstmal die
grundsätzlichen dokumente die du
wahrscheinlich benötigen wirst dein
personalausweis eine selbstauskunft dies
ist ein fragebogen den du ausfüllen
kannst damit ich dann vermieter besser
einschätzen kann zum beispiel kannst du
angaben über deine familie dort
reinschreiben eine schufa jeder
vermieter möchte wissen ob doch wirklich
deine miete zahlen kannst eine schufa
zeigt dass du noch keine schulden von
früheren wohnungen hast eine miet
bürgschaft manchmal musst du dem
vermieter zeigen dass du noch eine
andere person hast die für dich die
miete übernehmen würde
wenn du sie mal nicht zahlen kannst
einen arbeitsvertrag oder
einkommensnachweise vogue anzuschauen
wenn du nach einem wg-zimmer suchst
entweder stehst du auf facebook gruppen
bei ebay kleinanzeigen oder auf
webseiten wie zb wg gesucht oder
immobilienscout24
es gibt aber auch regionale webseiten
von jeder stadt wie fährt man fort wenn
du eine wg gefunden hast dir gefällt und
du ihnen eine e mail geschrieben hast
oder dein profil zugesendet hass und sie
dich zu einem wg casting einladen dann
kannst du feststellen auf die
mitbewohner passen ob du dich gut mit
ihnen verstehst manchmal gibt es aber
auch öffentliche zeiten für eine wohnung
in denen du einfach mit anderen suchen
zusammenkommt und die die wohnung
anschaust ein tipp für dich wenn du ganz
woanders wohnst und keine möglichkeit
hast mit den mitbewohnern persönlich in
kontakt zu kommen dann macht doch
einfach ein skype termin aus und dann
könnt ihr euch darüber kennen lernt
dinge die du nicht tun solltest ende
niemals geld an mieter die du noch nicht
persönlich kennengelernt hast
unterschreibe kein mietvertrag bevor du
nicht das zimmer persönlich angeschaut
hast
[Musik]
wir wissen bereits aus eigenen
erfahrungen wie frustrierend und wie
schwierig manchmal der weg bis zu einem
wg zimmer oder eine wohnung sein kann
wenn ihr noch tipps oder geschichten
darüber habt wie ein wg zimmer gefunden
habt dann schreibt jedoch gern ionen in
die kommentare
wir wünschen euch auf jeden fall jetzt
schon mal viel erfolg und viel glück
beim wohnungssuche wenn ihr jetzt noch
weiter deutsch lernen wollt dann schaut
auf gerne in unserer app siedlung ein
dort findet ihr viele interaktive
übungen ein gender trainer und einen
vokabeltrainer viel spaß beim weiter
lernen wenn du kein video mehr von
unserer passenden willst dann klickt
einfach hier unten auf die klingel
denn dann bekommst du eine nachricht
wenn wir ein neues video hier
veröffentlichen
jetzt sage ich nur noch vielen vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bis nächste
woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]